hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy welcome to the homeroom I guess
we say live stream and podcast although
we are pre-recording today's session
first of all happy International women's
day and we have a very exciting guest
today to talk about her life and the
internet and YouTube Susan waziski who
is the CEO of YouTube a small website
that you might have heard of that has to
deal with videos uh but before we jump
into that conversation where we talk
about uh all of those things I will give
my standard reminders first of all a
reminder that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization and we can
only exist through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please go
to Khan academy.org donate I also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up uh
especially during the pandemic when they
realized that Khan Academy's traffic was
three times normal and we're running at
a deficit and we wanted to accelerate a
whole bunch of things to support more
folks so special thanks to Bank of
America ATT google.org Novartis fastly
and General Motors for stepping up and
helping us fill that Gap but we do we
still need more support especially as we
go into 2021 so anything you can do is
much appreciated and then the last
announcement there is a version of this
of this live stream that you can get in
podcast form wherever you get your
podcast homeroom with Sal the podcast
so with that I am excited to introduce
Susan waziski Susan good to see you
thank you for having me Saul great to be
here
great to have you here and you know we
we've known each other for for a while
you know I've been known to do a few
things on YouTube
I can't even remember when we first met
it's been so long
oh it's probably on the order of 10
years and and I know your mother we we
don't live too far away from each other
and well there's so much I want to talk
to you about I think most people know
about YouTube but I think it's always
interesting to hear about
the organization from the the CEO's
point of view especially what do you
hope it becomes so in your what's your
best sense of the mission of YouTube or
what you think it can become over the
next let's say 10 years
yeah well so we have a mission so I'll
tell you what question is which is to
give everyone a voice and show them the
world and so if you look at the first
part to give everyone a voice how do we
enable anyone who wants to share
something with the world how to enable
them to do that so I think YouTube has
really made a lot of uh we've been
revolutionary in many ways right that we
have millions of channels and creators
but we still have a lot of work to do to
continue to enable people all over the
world to create video and make it easier
and continue to grow that but show them
the world I think that's actually where
we're really aligned in terms of our
mission so that people everywhere can
come to YouTube and learn anything they
want or experience any kind of music
entertainment look up any kind of
information and so I've also said that
YouTube in some ways is like a public
video library uh and we keep growing and
growing in terms of offering new topics
and how books from like books like
videos from new people uh and our goal
is just to continue to be a resource for
people around the world to learn and and
I've been really inspired by that I
sometimes see in different parts of the
world Wherever I Go people tell me what
they learned on YouTube so that's
something we want to continue to grow
I think that's a surprising thing you
know when YouTube was just starting to
get off the ground and people started to
associate it with you know just
entertainment but very quickly Humanity
realized that kind of knowledge could be
shared and I I actually think YouTube
will go down in world history as a
moment in human history where for you
know humans are separate themselves from
the rest of the animal kingdom by having
culture and having shared knowledge
which for many tens of thousands of
years happened through an oral tradition
then we invented a writing and then that
allowed it to persist and not kind of
lose information as that information
spread but writing loses a little bit of
the oral and now with on-demand video
and YouTube you and mass distribution of
it you kind of have all of the above
that any one person can express their
oral or their video or the visual
tradition and their knowledge and then
it's literally available to every human
being on the planet do you all ever view
yourselves that way it's like the Globes
I guess you did say this list of the
library it's the brain of the the
knowledge of humanity as being is
literally on YouTube
I definitely see the impact because
people everywhere tell me what they
learn and how especially now during the
pandemic we played a really key role a
lot of people had to do things for the
first time like fix something in their
house give a haircut uh learn a new
skill and the fact that YouTube could do
that and could be there in that moment
of Crisis was really really valuable so
I definitely understand that and our
goal is to continue to grow that and
support those use cases so everybody can
have that resource
absolutely and obviously most people who
are watching this many of them who are
watching it on on YouTube know that you
know I showed up on people's radar you
know Khan Academy has a lot of things we
have videos and exercises but it's the
YouTube that really helped people know
what what we're all about and was an
easy way to discover you mentioned
haircuts my wife watched a couple of
YouTube videos and you know I think it's
it's you know my hair has issues but
it's one of the better haircuts uh that
I've gotten I've fixed a toilet I fixed
the toilet twice uh over the last nine
months based on YouTube videos and I
think they're working so uh that's
absolutely true you know another on the
other side of that though there's a lot
of conversation about misinformation and
the spreading of you know how people get
into their own silos how do y'all think
about that on YouTube how do y'all try
to make sense of people who are
spreading misinformation or you know
people just gravitating to things that
already confirm whatever biases they
might have
said so great question and really
really huge amount of effort to figure
out the right solutions for that and so
basically we talk about all this work
around responsibility and so we we have
what we call the four r's of
responsibility and the first one is
about content that we would remove if it
is content that we think could lead to
real world harm so like let's just talk
about covid
um just to to put this in perspective so
there were different conspiracies that
came out like one of them was that covid
came from 5G cell towers and uh that's
that that it goes against all consensus
and so from medical consensus and so
that was something where we would say
that's clearly not true we need to
remove it because we also people were
destroying cell towers and uh we also
don't want people to go out and then do
risky Behavior so we are able to work
with medical professionals to find
content that was clearly
um that was clearly violative and again
we work with the medical professionals
on that
um but then we also raised up
information so information that was
um that we knew was
um
um that was accurate so like how to wash
your hands I never thought we'd serve so
many how to wash your hand videos
um we worked with 85 different health
professional organizations from around
the world uh and we made sure that all
of that information was delivered so
whether you did a search whether you
watched a video you could link and you
could see authoritative information and
then there's some content that's just
borderline like it might be something
that isn't really a big problem but it's
low quality and that's just something
that we are less likely to recommend to
our users because we want to give them
high quality information we don't want
them to come and see something that says
like aliens landed in your backyard
um that's very unlikely and so we again
we don't want to go too far and say hey
we're restricting Free Speech because
that's very important too that we can
enable a broad set of opinions and
perspectives
so that's that we also are reducing
information that is low quality in terms
of how we handle that in our
recommendations
you know that last point I always like
to clarify whenever people say that you
know this is reducing free speech I was
like you know free speech is the right
to say things that first of all you know
somehow do not undermine government or
would hurt people but you have the right
to say it but you don't have the right
for it to be Amplified by you know other
media companies if we go back 100 years
ago I could say whatever I want I could
complain about uh government or come up
with conspiracy theories but it doesn't
mean that the New York Times have to
publish whatever I had to say and
there's an analogy now that it does not
have to be validated or you don't have
to you don't have the right to be
Amplified so I think it's an interesting
Nuance yes you can't be arrested for
coming up with a conspiracy theory but
you also don't you can't just spread it
willy-nilly and say that's my that's
that's my right you know I I would love
to to dig a little bit into your journey
to becoming CEO of YouTube we have a lot
of young people who watch this it's
International women's day I think
there's a lot of young women who look up
to you as a real leader in industry
across the board when you were young
what were you like and is this what you
thought you were going to do
no I had no idea this is what I was
gonna do and maybe I'm showing my age by
saying this but we didn't have the
internet when I was young so I couldn't
even imagined that and uh I mean I I
think as a as a young kid what was I
like I first of all I was really into
doing arts and crafts I was really into
being creative and making things like I
would make paper and pot holders my
first business was making spice ropes
and selling them to my neighbor so I I
just like to make stuff that's a spice
rope I would I would braid yarn and then
tie cinnamon sticks to it and take
colored Fabric and put spices in there
and uh I just would make stuff and for
me what I this I had this realization
that
that technology was about creation it
was about making things and creating
things and that's what what a lot of
people didn't seem to see that
especially not then but I totally got I
was like wow I can make all kinds of
really interesting software and it can
be uh it can be distributed and so so
many people can see it and they can use
it and I can interact with them and and
and once I got that idea it was I I just
said like oh I have to be in Tech this
is the best field for me based on all my
interest with the creativity and making
things and seeing how I could have an
impact that way I I didn't know where it
was going to lead but as long as I was
making things I was happy and and that's
what got me started in Tech
no very similar to me it's all about
this notion of creation and that you can
create things that have incredible scale
CR incredible uh impact and once you
went into Tech what did you think you
were gonna actually how did you get
started where did you take a traditional
you know software engineering route
connect the dots between this interest
in creation and and where you are now
well I took a computer science class my
senior year in college I took the
computer science for computer science
majors and that at the time I thought oh
it's too late oh I'm too old like why am
I like I was a Humanities major so I was
like I must be too old to change careers
because I was funny when a 20 year old
says they're too old 21. well that was
too old I said 20 or 21 year old to
start learning computer science cool
because I had friends and they were
majored and they had taken them for
three years and they were about we're
all about to graduate and but I I
realized that I wanted to
do something in computer science and so
that was that was my first role or that
was my first yeah that's when I was
academically engaged with computer
science and then I grew up in the Palo
Alto area so I think that probably had
something to do with it and my I came
back after college and I wound up
working at this educational software
startup
um so here I am so I'm not that I don't
know many many years later on a working
with you
um around education so I had that
interest then I still have that interest
now but I was just a project manager for
making software for kids around
education
and I loved it it was creation it
involved I kids would write about how
they use the software how they learn
something and the impact it had
and so I just said like this is what I'm
gonna do I I'm so committed to this and
uh
anyway I can keep going you want to know
more well no I I do I actually never
knew about this this chapter I mean I'm
especially curious about what do you
think it was that you told yourself or
the skills that you brought to the table
that allowed you to really thrive in
this world and obviously uh you know
keep Rising through the ranks uh you
know you joined Google at a very early
stage and then now as CEO of YouTube
what what you know I know it's a hard
question to answer because you're a
humble person but be not so humble for a
few for a few seconds sure if I look
back at my career there were a few key
things that really helped me uh one of
them was first of all I was not looking
I was just looking to do something
interesting I was just thinking like how
can I use my skills to help create
something that will be used by people
and that will be useful and make the
world a better place and when I joined
Google I I was Employee 16 of Google
when I joined Google nobody thought that
Google was that interesting a company
but I saw that it was enabling people to
find information in new ways and so
being able to just focus on what was
important what I saw was adding value
whether or not other people agreed or
not was part of what helped me I think
it was the same thing for YouTube when I
first started working on YouTube nobody
thought it was that big a deal they
thought it was a small little
a company with like a lot of cats on
skateboards that wasn't really going
anywhere but I saw that people could use
it for creating and sharing ideas and
information and new musicians and and
artists and creators so seeing ideas
early and believing in them has
definitely helped me but then I would
say there's a part two which was maybe
less inspiration and more perspiration
which is just sticking with it and
working hard and not giving up and
getting through all the hard times and
just uh sticking with it keep keep
working on it keep uh waking up every
day thinking about how you can make the
company better and add value and and get
through the tough times so I'd say that
those are the two key Parts the
inspiration and the perspiration
it makes a lot of sense and I I have so
many questions for you but I know we
have a lot of questions that have come
in appropriately for you on video so we
the first question we have is from Izzy
if we could watch that video
I was wondering what you wanted to do
when you were my age and did you ever
think you'd be the CEO of a huge company
no I never thought I would be the CEO of
a huge company and when I was your age I
probably wanted to I was just interested
in a lot of different things I I didn't
really know what the future held for me
but I was interested in arts and crafts
I was interested in science I was
interested and
uh entrepreneurship but I would just
start things and like I said I taught I
would make things and sell it to my
neighbors and all of those turned out in
the end to be useful skills so I just
encourage all of you to explore the
world find what you love find the areas
that you want to keep working on and
that ultimately will lead you to
somewhere because you have to choose a
career to choose a profession it has to
be something that is Meaningful for you
or you'll it'll be much easier and
you'll do a better job if it's
meaningful to you so choose something
that you enjoy doing every day and that
you see benefits the world and that that
ultimately you derive meaning from
completely agree and the next question
we have is from Lily
for young women who are looking into
being in management positions or
positions of power what advice do you
have for them in trying to get past
those gender stereotypes of being too
pushy or too bossy when trying to
achieve their goals
so there definitely are a lot of there
are definitely a lot of challenges and
some of the ways that I have overcome
them is by first of all working really
hard which I'm sure all of you do and
um also I'd say with some of the
stereotypes and or people maybe who are
maybe not as supportive I've tried to
ignore the people who might be less
supportive and make friends with the
people who are and so I found it really
valuable over the course of my career to
figure out who my allies are to work
closely with them develop close
relationships with them and uh and just
continue doing the work that you're
doing and I do think we're at a time
where companies are working really hard
to have diverse workforces and because
we recognize that diversity makes a
stronger company makes a better product
and I encourage all of you to pursue
your passions and just to continue to
work hard and don't give up and find
your allies and if you find someone
who's not supportive just do your best
to just
um just do your best to you know keep
working through that
um and uh um certainly while there are
different stereotypes the stereotypes
are always changing and I really hope by
the time that a lot of you grow up that
some of the stereotypes you mentioned
are not anything that you have to face
in the future
and just following up on that you know
for those who don't know Susan you're
you and your siblings and your mother
are kind of famous as you know as
sisters all of you have been wildly
successful you know you have a sister
who's a physician you have a sister
who's a CEO of uh 23andMe uh your mother
is world famous as an educator a
journalism teacher etc etc is there
something that your mother gave you or
you had between yourselves as sisters
that you could share with kind of
sisters around the world that really
helped you
I wish I I wish I could say it was just
one thing but I I do think though one
thing my mom gave to all of us was
certainly the focus on
persistence
um believing in yourself and not getting
embarrassed so my mom was always the
first person to ask
um a hard question in an audience like
she used to always be the one who would
um say uh she felt like if she had been
wrong she needed to speak up about it
and sometimes as a kid that was really
embarrassing but I learned over time
it's really important to use your voice
it's really important to say what you
believe and to speak up for yourself and
I do think that those skills have helped
all of us because if you believe in
yourself you speak up for yourself but
you're working hard and doing a great
job of what you're doing you're going to
find a way to be successful and I think
that we learned a lot of skills from my
mom and my dad who's the professor and
who was consistently hard-working and uh
and
and we learned that that's that those
are all things that it takes and if you
keep it up and work hard it it'll let
end up with something that is compelling
for you
yeah well we have another question here
from imari
okay some activities or actions that you
recommend for young women entering
College to prepare them for Career
Success
for self for Career Success for people
who are entering college or entering the
workforce I would really encourage you
to think about what is Meaningful for
you because it's very hard to do a job
that you don't like you have to find
something that is really speaks to you
and I see that among my own kids and and
all the kids that I work with that
people come from very different places
and they're very different passions that
people have and and so to the extent
that you can look inside yourself and
think about what would be really
meaningful for you and find a way to
explore that and that if your work
speaks to you in a deep way and you take
meaning from it it will it will help you
get through the hard times it will help
you stick with it and make a difference
so I encourage you just to really think
about what your passions are and you
have to be practical too realistically I
think that's something I learned from my
mom also like I would have probably said
oh if you had asked me as a kid I've
always said oh I just want to be like an
artist and and draw pictures and you
know make candles and and as compelling
as all that is I also she also
encouraged me like yes you need to be
able to make a living you have to be
able to do something where you can
support yourself so marrying the two of
what your passion is but where there's
market and demand for the things that
you're interested in that would be those
are good places for you to look at
Future careers and I also encourage
people to look at things that are
growing like in many ways I benefited
from being in Tech which was a growing
industry so there were always new jobs
there was always something new to
explore and so the extent that you you
can choose an area that is expanding
that the whole area is growing it's
going to be easier to get more jobs it's
going to be easier to get promoted so
that's another thing to consider as you
factor your future career in and what
areas you're going to go into
I love that advice I always tell folks
actually on one part of your brain you
should be hyper pragmatic look at the
industries that are growing that
compensate well and that you know are
bearable you you can enjoy working in
that but as you do that carve out some
space to also be hyper idealistic and
have your passions and we're in a unique
time I mean YouTube shows us this my
narrative shows us your narrative shows
this that those things will intersect in
surprising ways there's ways to publish
your passions there's other people in
the world that will also have those
passions and it can turn into a a career
in and of itself there's another
question here from Ruby
you must have faced a lot of obstacles
getting to where you are today and I'm
wondering if you felt like giving up if
so how are you able to overcome that
thank you
oh great question
yeah great question I definitely have
had hard days and there have been
moments where I have felt like giving up
but I've often realized that if I give
up
then
well then I don't get to keep doing what
I love doing and
if I give up because someone was
difficult like well then they win and
they get what they want and I don't I
don't get to continue to make my points
of view heard so
I usually
when I have a bad day I just call it a
night and I go to bed early and I wake
up and some most days like I feel ready
to do it again and ready to revisit the
situation and I find a way to smooth
over whatever was really hard and I
encourage you just to just to find
something you love and stick with it
yeah and I always remind folks you know
there's no movie where you're like the
protagonist does not have to deal with
adversity so whatever those adverse
moments happen say well this is just
part of my movie and a movie would not
be interesting without these moments and
you're absolutely right the things that
you think are existential crises it you
know within reason a week later you're
like I just have to power through it
there's ways that that it can sometimes
uh get better and you just have to
sometimes realize it it you know staying
in the game is half the battle
many times things didn't go the way I
wanted then many times things failed and
many times I made mistakes and then I
had to come back and say oh I learned
from that but
some of some of my
that's how life is and and what you what
makes you stronger is overcoming that
and and internalizing that and saying
well what did I what did I learn from
that and how can I change how my life is
going forward and if you are
continuously learning if you are having
as many experiences and then benefiting
from them and figuring out how you can
do everything better then
that that all adds up and and there are
a lot of times where we're at work and
people come to me with different ideas
and be like oh I I'll say I know I know
about doing that because I didn't it
didn't work
um I can tell you why because there are
a lot of things I've done that have not
worked and but that but I learned from
it and I'm not doing them again and I'm
actually telling other people too like
don't do that
um sometimes I even say hey you know
what you can try it the world's
different like maybe things have changed
and and so I'm also open to how
something could be different now than it
was in the past but I tell them like
this is why it didn't work for me you
should take that into consideration as
you consider your future plans
you know related to that when people
look at you when I look at you you're
like oh Susan you know Titan of tech has
it all figured out she's made it
what what are the things that you feel
that you feel sometimes unsure about or
that you stress about because I think
that's something you know it's very easy
we all know what the things we all we
stress about but when we look at the
suicide of the world like we have it
they have it figured out so you know
show us that you're like the rest of us
well they're definitely
a lot of times I'm doing things I've
never done before so just because Tech
is in a new place that it's never been
before and we're having to figure out a
lot of challenging situations based on
the size or where we are and how we can
do better and
um
I mean there's so many so many different
examples and I mean maybe I can just
think of like all the times that my kids
have told me how we've screwed up
um and and I actually just think that uh
it when you screw up you
um you should just say that like and
just be honest about it and so so uh you
know I look at like our rewind video
that we did two years ago it was the
most disliked video on the internet
um
maybe I was in a under under a rock
someplace but the most disliked every
kid on this video they know what I'm
talking about they know
about this video that other videos on
YouTube had taken years to discuss have
this many dislikes and then our video in
a matter of weeks like sorry a matter of
a week of days became the most disliked
video on the internet and so I just was
like yeah the video was cringy my kids
were like it was cringy
um I was like okay it was a cringy video
so what we made the worst video like the
most disliked video fine like we just
we'll make something different next year
um and so sometimes you just gotta go
with yeah we made a mistake things
didn't go well so I can tell you like at
that moment it was not uh people at
YouTube were not feeling good that the
video was becoming the most disliked
video on the internet
so but you learn from it and and and I
think having some humor about it too
sometimes is you know when you can when
it's something like that where you can
just say let's just laugh and move on
no and I have to say it takes an
incredible security to bring up you know
if you ask me to bring up and I have
them my major failures over the last
year three years ten years
there's a part of my brain says Sal
don't bring it up then people are going
to know you know all your weaknesses
takes a lot to to bring that up uh but I
really appreciate that we have another
question from Imani
I was just curious what strong women
have inspired or in
or into you to become the powerful
leader that you are today
who has inspired me well many people
along the way my mom definitely inspired
me
and as a kid I was always really
impressed with Marie Curie and she was
my icon as a as a kid she is someone who
holds two Nobel prizes and I don't think
there are a lot of other people who have
achieved that in different fields and
her daughter also has a Nobel Prize
which I always thought was really
impressive so uh she was my one of my
icons and
but I would also say that a lot of the
people who mentored me and helped me get
to where I am were not always they were
not always women in fact most of the
time they were men because most of the
people in positions above me at at
Google
um in Tech were men and and there were a
lot of super supportive uh mentors that
I had and I I always remind people like
whether they're a mentee or a mentor
that anyone like anyone regardless of
their backgrounds you can mentor someone
they don't have to look like you or be
like you you can just uh find someone
who is talented that that you want to
mentor and and you're again your mentors
can be different from the backgrounds
you came from and they can be really
helpful to you so I'm very thankful for
all the people who mentored me along the
way even though they came from different
backgrounds than I did and they
definitely helped me and I definitely
learned from them
absolutely and you know I know I know
we're running low on time I could talk
to you for hours there's so many
questions I have about your life about
YouTube I am you know we touched on the
subject of learning obviously Khan
Academy is very focused on learning and
YouTube has been a big part of that that
Journey when I was making content from
my cousins and and still do I made three
videos that I upload onto YouTube
yesterday so I'm still very active there
what's your what's your what's your
dream if you if you fast forward 5 10 20
years for
you know I don't know if you think in
terms of Legacy but you know the impact
that you want to have through YouTube
so we definitely think about YouTube and
how we can continue to grow it and I'm
always just amazed of all the new topics
and new ways that we can enable voices
around the world to come and to share
their story and so part of our goal is
to enable the next generation of
storytellers and to help them be able to
to do that and to make a business and
the flip side of that is is that we can
have incredibly compelling content for
people around the world on any topic and
so if you look at if you look at YouTube
I see that we bring mini value and of
course like enabling all the fun videos
and music videos but we also deal with a
lot of really important topics that just
were not talked about before
um whether that involves mental health
issues or hearing from people of
different backgrounds it never were
represented It On Media traditionally
like those are really compelling and
important points of view and just you
know what one last question it feels
like there's two competing wins there is
you know one wind where there's more
tools and resources YouTube Khan Academy
you know all the other things that
Google provides that are enabling the
individual to publish to express
themselves to discover points of view to
learn it really does feel like we're an
inflection point in a Renaissance so to
speak in Human Society on the other side
there are reasons why people can get
cynical it feels like we are more
polarized as a country or as a world it
feels like you know inequity is growing
it feels like people aren't listening to
each other anymore you know the
climate's in trouble
if there's a young person watching and
and there's a pandemic and and people
are feeling isolated and lonely
what what message can you can you give
to someone who's kind of trying to
navigate these these two currents
YouTube does enable people to connect
with each other as humans and there's
something very human about the fact that
people are a lot of times going to
YouTube and talking about how they feel
what their deepest challenges were about
diseases they have and there's something
really cathartic about people going and
sharing the challenges that they have
and we've seen other people really be
able to relate and benefit from that so
I do see a human connection that's
incredibly powerful on YouTube for us to
understand each other more as humans and
I've also seen that there are there's an
incredible amount of good that comes
whether it's something like
um the the 20 million trees that are
being planted
um and organized on YouTube or
fundraisers to support people during
hard times and so I do see that YouTube
can be used for all of kinds of good
outcomes and I encourage you to use like
you know YouTube and all social
platforms if there's a cause you believe
in you can make a difference you can
make a video you can organize groups and
I encourage you to speak your voice and
now is the best time ever to be able to
do that so I encourage you to do what's
important for you and to speak up
now thank you so much for that I'm
inspired I'm gonna go use some social
media to try to try to change the world
well Susan thank you so much I know
you're incredibly busy and thank you for
making the time out for all of us and
all the students who are watching and
their questions uh and uh you know I I
I'm excited to be part of your journey
uh which you you are empowering Khan
Academy on so many levels uh and and see
where where we can take the world
oh thank you and I'm and I'm glad we
have been part of your journey too
thanks everyone for joining as uh you
could tell you know these conversations
uh when you have a guest like Susan I
could I could talk for hours so much to
learn from and I find her to be
incredibly inspiring and you know I've
I've known Susan and her family for many
years now uh and uh you know every time
I chat uh it's I never cease to be
impressed by uh what actually her and
her sisters and her mother are
accomplishing on a regular basis so uh
thank you all for joining we do have
we're actually going to have a our next
show is March 10th the guest is Mark
Sternberg it'll actually be hosted by
Khan Academy's Chief learning officer
Kristen deserbo and they're going to be
talking this is a mark Sternberg from
the Walton family foundation and we'll
talk about philanthropy and learning and
impact on education so look forward to
seeing all of you all there uh have a
good weekend